-Guys, whenever I get
some down time here at the show,
I like to go on Instagram and
scroll through all the photos.
-Really?
-And one thing I've noticed
is that a lot of times,
two people
will write the exact same
caption,
but the pictures they post
will be completely different.
-Oh, no.
-I'll show you --
[ Laughter ]
Did he say "Oh, no?"
-Yeah.
-I'll show you what I mean
in this next segment.
It's time for "Picture This."
Here we go.
-♪ Picture this, picture this,
picture this ♪
♪ Yeah, picture this ♪
-[ Laughs ] Having a small crowd
is so fun,
but it's also really personal.
I get to hear
every single person's opinion.
Yeah.
So I said there's the same
caption, different photos
and he said --
-Oh, no.
-Yeah. That's right.
[ Laughter ]
So, let's take a look
at this first example.
It's from Tesla and Microsoft.
-Oh, no.
-They both wrote...
Tesla posted a picture
of their new electric car.
Microsoft posted
a picture of...
Bill Gates.
Do you see what I'm saying?
You understand?
-Same caption.
Different post.
The next one is from
President Obama
and President Biden.
They both wrote...
President Obama posted
a picture of...a UFO.
President Biden posted
a picture of...
an iPhone.
Where's my man?
Can we cut to him?
Yeah, stand up.
Yeah, yeah, there he goes.
This guy works --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
We talked to him
before the show.
He's representing -- He works
at the Apple Store,
and so any Apple humor,
you laugh doubly.
-Right.
-Yeah.
What's your name?
-My name's David.
-David, are you a Genius?
-Am I what?
-A Genius?
-I'm a specialist.
-Mm.
-A specialist.
-So wait --
-There's a hierarchy at Apple.
You start as a specialist,
go to an expert, then a Genius.
-Oh, so right now you're a
specialist, not yet an expert.
-I just finished
my freshman year.
[ Laughter ]
-Who are you pointing at?
-Over there?
Do we teach a course here?
[ Laughter ]
What's your major?
-I was a musical theater major.
I went for musical theater
and opera
at the University of Montevallo.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you have a --
David, did you have
a go-to song?
Did you have something that
you used to love to sing?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, David!
-David, I'll hold this
out to you.
We've got to be six feet away.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't mess around.
David, stay there. Stay there.
Yeah.
And I'll just hold this.
It's for COVID reasons, I think.
But, okay.
David, what's your last name?
-Poehler, like Amy Poehler.
-Yeah, oh, my God.
David Poehler.
All right, great.
Here's David Poehler
with his audition doing --
-"Tomorrow" from "Annie."
-Oh, my God.
Wow.
Do we have time for that?
Oh, my God.
Alright.
-♪ The sun'll come out
tomorrow ♪
♪ Bet your bottom dollar
that tomorrow ♪
-♪ There'll be sun ♪
-Let's go to the part.
-♪ Tomorrow, tomorrow ♪
-♪ I love ya tomorrow ♪
♪ You're always a day ♪
♪ Awaaaaaaaaaa... ♪
-That's how you do it!
-♪ ...aaaaaaaaay ♪
-David Poehler!
That's how you do it
right there!
Thank you very much.
Thank you for being here, buddy.
That was unbelievable.
Wow!
Talented crowd!
Thank you, Roots.
Oh, he's got pipes.
He's got pipes.
No wonder he's yelling
in the crowd.
Yeah! He's gotta sing!
-He's gotta sing.
-We're still doing -- Yeah.
-We got bits?
-We're still doing this bit.
Yeah, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Check out this photo here.
This next one's from
the Girl Scouts
and "Entertainment Weekly."
-Oh. Girl Scouts and
"Entertainment Weekly."
-They both wrote...
Girl Scouts posted
a picture of...a troop.
"Entertainment Weekly"
posted a picture of...
the cast of "Knives Out 2."
I guess they just keep
adding people.
This next one is from
J.Lo and Ben Affleck.
[ Audience ohs ]
They both wrote...
J.Lo posted a picture of...
Ben Affleck.
Ben Affleck posted
a picture of...
the CDC's current
mask guidelines.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wear them.
Don't wear them.
Yes. I can? No. Can't.
Mask. Mask up.
Here's one from Guy Fieri
and "Politico."
They both wrote...
Guy Fieri posted
a picture of...a rack of ribs.
"Politico"
posted a picture of...
Mitch McConnell.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Why would they do that?
-Why would they --
I would think that's offensive.
-That seems odd.
-That seems odd to me.
-That seems rude and mean.
-All right. Here's the last one.
It's from Bill de Blasio
and Andrew Yang.
They both wrote...
Bill de Blasio
posted a picture of...
unvaccinated New Yorkers
going maskless.
Andrew Yang
posted a picture of...
Bill de Blasio in Nets gear.
That's all the time we have
for "Picture This."